عندما قمنا بالتسلسل ، قمنا بالتسلسل في
أجزاء صغيرة قصيرة وهذه حقًا هي
التقنية التي تسمح لنا بالتسلسل في
قطع طويلة ضخمة ووضعها معًا
مثل أحجية الصور المقطعة بالطريقة
الصحيحة وبالتالي أجزاء من الجينوم حيث
يصعب استيعاب تلك القطع حتى  لقد
حصلت على تلك الخيوط الطويلة الكبيرة التي تمكنا الآن
من وضعها بشكل صحيح في
القطع الصحيحة وتجميع لغز المنشار الكامل
هذا ، إنه أمر لا يصدق إلى حد كبير ، ولا أعتقد
أننا نقتل الناس حقًا في
فهم الاتساع ومدى أهمية هذا على ما
أعتقد  سنفعل في المستقبل عندما
تبدأ الأمور بالحدوث ويمكننا أن نرى الأدوية
والأشياء والعلاجات
للأمراض المستعصية رسميًا ،
دعنا نعود إلى سوزانا
الفتاة الصغيرة الجميلة ، إنها مريضتك
كيف يحدث اضطراب وراثي مثل حدث
ذلك في حالتها الخاصة مثلها  كان أبي
يقول إنه لم يرث من
والدتها أو والدها ، لقد بدأ الأمر تلقائيًا
وكانت أول فرد في
عائلتها مع هذا وسيقول لي الكثير من الناس
د.  علقت ، لدينا جينات نظيفة
في عائلتنا ، هذا لا يمكن أن يكون وراثيًا ، لكن
في الواقع هذه إحدى الطرق
التي يمكن أن تكون وراثية ، هناك آخرون ولكن
طريقة مهمة
على الرغم من أن حالة سوزانا
مدمرة لقد قابلت سوزانا
منذ عدة سنوات و  لقد مرت
بتدهور تدريجي ولذا فهي
تقاتل حرفيًا من أجل حياتها
وهذا ما يحدث مع بعض هذه
الحالات والأمل في
أن يضعنا التشخيص الآن في
اتجاه علاج وربما حتى علاج
لبعض الأشخاص ، لذا فإن الأول
وأهم جزء في هذا اللغز
ومساعدة سوزانا هو أنك يجب أن
تكتشف ما الذي تصححه تمامًا ،
فأنت لا تعرف تمامًا طريقة المسيرة ،
هل ستذهب إلى اليسار ، هل ستذهب إلى اليمين ،
هل ستصعد أم تنزل؟
يجب أن يكون لديك هذا التشخيص دون
التشخيص بأنك تتجول في
البرية ولكن مع التشخيص
فجأة ، لديك الآن خريطة طريق أفضل في
المستقبل ، ما الذي يمكنك توقعه ما الذي يمكنك
منعه من تناول الأدوية  rk
فجأة لديك الآن فرصة محتملة
للعلاجات الجينية الآن
هذه العلاجات الجينية ليست حقيقة
بالنسبة لمعظم هذه الحالات حتى الآن ،
لكن الكثير من العلماء يعملون
بجد على ذلك وأنا متفائل جدًا
في العشرة القادمة  سنوات سيكون الكثير
منهم قابلاً للعلاج ،
كنت سأضعك على المقعد الساخن لطرح
السؤال الذي أعتقد أن أي والد أو أي
شخص حقًا حتى لو لم يكن لديك
المرض الوراثي ،
عندما قد يلتقي الأبيض ، فلماذا ومتى؟  نرى
علاجًا أو علاجًا
مؤثرًا حقًا على الأشخاص ، لذلك
لا أعرف أنني لست
جيدًا في التنبؤ ، لكنني سأعطيك
مثالًا أعتقد أنه رائع ،
هناك حالة وراثية كانت
في الماضي  اعتاد أن يكون السبب الجيني الأكثر شيوعًا
لوفاة الأطفال الذين تقل
أعمارهم عن عامين ، وهو حالة تسمى
الضمور العضلي النخاعي ،
ولدينا الآن علاج جيني واحد
ويتم تشخيصه والأطفال الذين تم تشخيصهم عند
الولادة من فحص حديثي الولادة.
نأمل الآن أن
تعيش حياة صحية طبيعية بعد ذلك ، لذلك هناك بعض
قصص النجاح ، فهي قليلة العدد ،
لكن هناك أشياء لمرض فقر الدم المنجلي ،
وأمراض أخرى ،
وهي واحدة من هذه الأشياء بمجرد أن
تعمل التكنولوجيا ، سيكون هناك
اختراق حيث لا يقتصر الأمر على  نوعًا ما
بشكل تدريجي واحدًا تلو الآخر ، لكنه
سيكون عبارة عن مجموعات من مئات الحالات
التي يمكن معالجتها بنفس
التقنية ، لذلك هذا ما ننتظره جميعًا
على حافة مقعدنا
هو أن هذه التقنيات ستكون آمنة
وفعالة الآن  فتح الإجابات
لملايين الأشخاص
[موسيقى]